This segment is probably
the most critical one
for the purpose of understanding
what the Poisson process really
is and how it behaves.
There will be almost no
mathematical formulas.
But the segment
will be quite dense
in terms of
conceptual reasoning.
So pay a lot of attention.
In a nutshell, we will argue
that the Poisson process has
memorylessness properties that
are entirely similar to those
that we have seen for
the Bernoulli process.
This should not be surprising,
since the Poisson process can
be thought of as a limiting
case of the Bernoulli process.
We will reason through
these properties,
not in the style of a
formal mathematical proof,
but with an intuitive argument.
But I would like to assure you
that the intuitive argument can
be translated into
a rigorous proof.
The first property
is the following.
The process starts at time 0.
You come in and start
watching at let's say time 7.
Or more generally,
instead of time 7,
suppose that you
come in and start
watching at some time, little t.
The important thing here is
that little t is a constant.
It's a deterministic number.
Starting at that time,
what will you see?
Well, the original
process was Poisson.
This means that
disjoint intervals
in the original process
are independent.
Therefore, disjoint
intervals in the process
that you will be seeing
will also be independent.
Furthermore, during any
little interval of length
delta in the
process that you see
will still have
probability lambda times
delta, approximately,
of seeing and arrival.
Therefore, what you see also
satisfies the properties
of a Poisson process, and
is itself a Poisson process.
Second, the original
process was Poisson.
So different intervals
are independent.
So whatever happens
in this interval
is independent from whatever
happens in that interval.
But that interval corresponds
to the future of the process,
and therefore, the future of the
process, what you get to see,
is independent from
the past history.
And so the conclusion is that
the process that you get to see
is a Poisson process, which
is independent of the history
until the time that
you started watching.
And we say, therefore,
that what you see
is a fresh starting process.
The Poisson process
starts fresh at time t.
We have the fresh
start property.
And similar to the language we
use for the Bernoulli process,
the fresh start property means
that you see a process that's
independent of
the past and which
has the same statistical
properties as if this was time
0, as if the process was
just starting right now.
One consequence of this
fresh start property
is the following.
You start watching at time t.
And you're interested
in the time
it takes until the next arrival.
What are the properties
of this random variable?
Well, since you have a fresh
starting Poisson process
at this time, this is the
time until the first arrival
in this fresh starting
Poisson process.
And the time until
the first arrival
in a process that
is just starting,
we know that it has an
exponential distribution.
So this is going to be an
exponential random variable
with the same parameter, lambda.
Furthermore, because the
process starts fresh,
whatever happens in the future
is independent from the past.
And so this random variable,
the remaining time,
is independent of whatever
happened in the past until time
t.
Now let us look at a
somewhat different situation.
You start watching the
process at time T1.
Time T1 is the time
of the first arrival.
And you start
watching from here on.
What is it that
you're going to see?
Suppose that the
first arrival happens,
let's say, at time equal to 3.
So we're conditioning
on this event.
In that case, you start
watching the process at time 3.
And you also know that the first
arrival happened at time 3.
But this fact about the first
arrival happening at time 3
belongs to the history of
the process until time 3.
This is information
about the past,
and does not affect what is
going to happen after time 3.
The process after time 3 will
be independent from the history
until time 3 and whatever
happened until that time.
So starting at that particular
time 3, what you see
is a Poisson process that is
independent from the past.
Now, this argument
is valid even if I
were to use here a
3.5 or 3.4 or 3.7.
No matter when this
first arrival occurred,
what I see starting
from this time
is a Poisson process which
is independent from the past.
At the time of
the first arrival,
the process just starts fresh.
As a consequence of this, and by
repeating the argument that we
carried out for the remaining
time until the next arrival
up here, we can
repeat this argument
and argue that the time
until the next arrival
in this fresh
starting process, this
will also be an exponential
random variable.
Now, this time until
the next arrival
is the difference between
the second arrival
time and the first arrival time.
And we denote it by T2.
What we just argued is that
this time until the next arrival
is going to be an
exponential random variable.
And also, it is
independent from the past.
And in particular, it
is independent from T1.
So the time until
the second arrival,
starting from the first arrival,
the second inter-arrival time
is a random variable that has
an exponential distribution that
is the same distribution
as that of T1,
and is independent from T1.
Now we can extend this
argument and look at the kth
inter-arrival time.
For example, if the
arrival numbered k minus 1
occurred here, and the
k arrival occurs here,
this difference, here
we denote it by Tk,
and by arguing in a similar
way that the process starts
fresh at this particular time,
the time until the next arrival
will also be an
exponential random variable
with the same distribution.
And furthermore,
will be independent
from the past history,
and therefore,
independent from the
earlier inter-arrival times.
And this has lots of
important implications.
For example, the time
until the kth arrival,
which is the sum of the
first k inter-arrival times,
is the sum of independent,
identically distributed,
exponential random variables.
In particular, this means
that we can find the PDF of Yk
by convolving the
exponential PDF
of these inter-arrival times,
convolving this exponential PDF
with itself k times.
And this is indeed one
way to find the PDF of Yk.
But fortunately for us,
we were able to find it
with a much simpler argument.
And we already know what it is.
But this property here is
also useful for finding
the mean and the variance of Yk.
The mean of the sum is
the sum of the means.
And since the random
variables are independent,
the variance of the sum is
the sum of the variances.
We know what is the mean and
the variance of an exponential.
And so by multiplying
that by k, we
obtain the mean of
the kth arrival time
and the variance of
the kth arrival time.
And so we now know
the mean and variance
of the Erlang PDF of order k.
A second implication
of this property
is more theoretical,
more conceptual.
Recall that we defined
the Poisson process
in terms of an
independence assumption
and an assumption on the
probability of arrivals
during a small interval.
But we could have defined the
Poisson process as follows.
Consider a sequence of
independent, identically
distributed exponentials.
Call them Tk.
And use these to define
the arrival times.
This is a way of
constructing a process.
What we argued in
this segment is
that a Poisson process under
the original definition
satisfies this new definition.
One can complete
the argument to show
that the two definitions
are equivalent.
It is possible to argue
that if we define an arrival
process in this manner, this
arrival process will also
satisfy the basic properties
of the Poisson process.
This argument can
indeed be carried out,
but we will not go through it.
A final implication, which
is a little more practical.
If you want to simulate
the Poisson process,
how would you do it?
Given what we now know, the most
natural way is the following.
We generate independent,
identically distributed,
exponential random
variables, using
for example a random
number generator.
And then use these
exponential random variables
to construct the values of
the inter arrival times.
And this way, construct
a complete time history
of the Poisson process.